great creativity in times of need
we need great creativity discuss
great creativity is astonishingly
absurdly rationally irrationally
powerful
great creativity can spread tolerance
champion freedom
make education seem like a bright idea
great creativity can turn a spotlight on
deprivation
or show that deprivation ain't
necessarily so
great creativity can make politicians
electable or parties unelectable
it can make war seem like tragedy
or farce
creativity is the meme maker that puts
slogans on our t-shirts and phrases on
our lips
it's the pathfinder that shows us a
simple road through an impenetrable
moral maze
science is clever
but great creativity is something less
knowable more magical
and now we need that magic this is a
time of need our climate is changing
quickly too quickly
and great creativity is needed to do
what it does so well to provoke us to
think differently with dramatic creative
statements
to tempt us to act differently with
delightful creative scraps here is one
such scrap from an initiative i'm
involved in using creativity to inspire
people to be greener you know rather
than drive today i'm gonna walk
and so he walked and as he walked he saw
things strange and wonderful things he
would not otherwise have seen a deer
with an itchy leg a flying motorcycle
father and daughter separated from a
bicycle by a mysterious wall
and then he stopped
walking in front of him was her
the woman who as a child had skipped
with him through fields and broken his
heart
sure she had aged a little in fact she
aged a lot but he felt all his old
passion for her return
ford he called softly that was her name
don't say another word gusty she said
for that was his name i know a tent next
to a caravan exactly 300 yards from here
let's go there make love
in the tent ford undressed she spread
one leg and then the other
gusty entered her boldly and made love
to her rhythmically while she filmed him
because she was a keen amateur
pornographer
the earth moved for both of them and
they live together happily ever after
and all because he decided to walk that
day
we've got the science we've had the
debate the moral imperative is on the
table
great creativity is needed to take it
all
make it simple and sharp to make it
connect to make it make people want to
act so this is a call a plea to the
incredibly talented ted community let's
get creative against climate change and
let's do it soon thank you
you